nos dicen que esta es la gráfica de la
función efe la tenemos aquí y luego nos
dicen que la función que se define como
g b x es igual a un tercio de fx cuál es
la gráfica de g y si lo estuviéramos
haciendo en khan academy tiene múltiples
opciones
esta es una captura de pantalla de
nuestra aplicación móvil y pensé que
podríamos intentar dibujarlo pausa este
vídeo e imagina cómo crees que se verá
la gráfica de ge o al menos como lo
abordaría muy bien se ve x es igual a un
tercio de fx así que por ejemplo podemos
ver aquí que f de 3 es igual a menos 3
entonces 73 debe ser un tercio de eso
así que debería ser menos 1 del mismo
modo g de 3 estaría justo allí y de la
misma manera g de menos 3 cuánto sería
bueno efe - 3 estrés entonces que de
menos 3 va a ser un tercio de eso o va a
ser igual a 1
efe de 0 es 0 un tercio de eso sigue
siendo 0 entonces ya de 0 todavía va a
estar justo ahí
y sabemos que eso va a suceder aquí y
aquí también y así ya tenemos una idea
de cómo se verá esta gráfica la función
g se verá algo así solo estoy conectando
los puntos y nos dieron algunos puntos
que podemos usar como puntos de
referencia entonces la gráfica de g se
verá más o menos así se aplana un poco o
se hace un poco delgada y se ve así y
debes elegir la opción que se parezca a
esto hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí se nos dice que la gráfica de fx se
define por esta expresión cual es la
gráfica de gx y g x es esto
pausa este vídeo y piénsalo de nuevo muy
bien ahora la clave para hacer esto es
parece que x es como si fueras a tomar
todos los términos de fx y los
multiplicadas por 2 o al menos como si
fueras a multiplicar el valor absoluto
por 2 y luego este menos 2 x 2 así que
parece que gm x es igual a 2 por fx
podríamos poner una tabla aquí esta es
otra de las formas en que podemos pensar
en esto podemos pensar en x podemos
pensar en fx y ahora podemos pensar en
que x que debería ser dos veces esto así
que podemos ver que cuando x es igual a
cero fx es igual a 1 ig x debería ser
igual a 2 porque es igual a 2 por fx así
que de 0 va a ser igual a 2 que pasa
cuando x es igual
digamos que cuando x es igual a 3
cuando x es igual a 3 fm x es menos 2 gx
va a ser igual a 2 veces eso porque es
igual a 2 por fx entonces va a ser igual
a menos 4 entonces quede x o debería
decir g de 3 va a ser menos 4 va a estar
justo aquí y tal vez pensemos en un
punto más
efe de 5 es igual a 0 g de 5 será 2 por
0 que es igual a 0 así que va a estar
justo ahí y así en la gráfica se va a
ver como algo así en realidad solo estoy
conectando los puntos tratando de
dibujar algunas líneas rectas se verá
algo así se puede ver que está un poco
estirada en la dirección vertical
entonces si estuvieras haciendo esto en
khan academy sería de elección múltiple
y buscaría una gráfica que se pareciera
a esto vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
más aquí nos dicen la función g es una
versión escalada verticalmente de la
función f así que podemos ver que g es
una versión escalada verticalmente de f
las funciones están graficadas donde f
es una línea continua y g es punteada
podemos ver lo cual es la ecuación de g
en términos de f pausa este vídeo y
trata de pensar lo bueno la forma en que
voy a abordar esto una vez más es con
una tabla y veamos la relación entre f y
g entonces esta columna es x esta
columna es fx y luego esta columna es
que de x veamos algunos puntos
interesantes en realidad podría elegir 0
pero quizás el 0 es menos interesante
que este punto que tenemos aquí entonces
cuando x es igual a menos 3
efe de menos 3 es menos 3 cuanto es g de
menos 3 parece que es menos 9
cuando x es cero efe de cero es menos 2
cuanto es g de 0 es igual a menos 6 y ya
vemos un patrón para cualquier valor de
f que es igual a 3 por eso para
cualquier valor de f que es igual a 3
por eso y ni siquiera necesitamos estas
columnas tan grandes podemos ver que el
gx es igual a 3 por fx entonces esta es
la ecuación de g en términos de f